bonjour à tous vous allez poursuivre
dans un instant on dirait que la séance
de questions cribles le thème
aujourd'hui c'est la réforme
territoriale
une réforme qui soulève beaucoup de
mécontentement à gauche comme à droite
le texte doit être présenté la semaine
prochaine en conseil des ministres mais
le débat parlementaire prévu cet été
risquent de virer à la bataille rangée
pour l'exécutif une partie des
socialistes refusant le redécoupage des
régions tel qu'il a été pensé à l'elysée
est défendu par matignon voilà tout film
donc contre le direct dans l'hémicycle
un rite orial en cours au plan financier
la ponction de 11 milliards de tout à
sion les menaces de sanction de mise à
la diète de conditionnement des
dotations de mutualisation force et
contredisent le concept de libre
administration de nos collectivités
locales toutes ces intentions
gouvernementales vont à l'encontre du
débat que nous avions partagé dans le
cas de ma proposition de loi visant à
revaloriser la dgf des communes de moins
de vingt mille habitants au plan
politique
votre réforme contredit frontalement les
grandes réformes de décentralisation des
années 1980 et en pot impose une vision
vertical de la politique du haut ou vers
le bas ou entre l'état et les communes
les régions et les métropoles et les
intercommunalités seront les acteurs et
les est obligé enfin au plan humain
les non-dits de la réforme qui vont
vider les communes de leurs compétences
au profit des intercommunalités qui vont
tuer la démocratie de proximité le lien
social qui s'opère autour des
associations des écoles des bénévoles et
des élus locaux tous ses étés garçons
prévisible qu'ils soient de caractère
financier démocratique ou humain ne
croyez vous pas qu'il est urgent de
consulter les élus les personnels
territoriaux et les populations afin
d'entendre la france rurale au lieu de
vous conformer aux exigences de
bruxelles du medef et des prêteurs
institutionnels
merci la parole comme la maryse
lebranchu mise de décentralisation et de
la fonction publique oui merci mais
c'est le président mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
gérard le calme servira dans j'enlève
chargé
nous avons
longuement débattue et est depuis
longtemps de cette évolution la question
qu'on peut se poser aujourd'hui qu'on
doit se poser ensemble au delà des
divergences d'à priori que nous pouvons
avoir c'est les communes peuvent-elles
entre guillemets permettez moi cette
expression tenir le coup face à une
forte demande des services de la part de
leur population et une demande qu'il
faut que nous regardions ensemble de
services halte-garderie services à la
petite enfance etc etc on en a parlé
souvent nous sommes à un moment de notre
histoire où
nos citoyens
demandent des services et nous ne
pouvons plus la réponse si nous restons
les uns et les autres je dis nous allons
nous collectif et équivalents dans nos
communes je voudrais vous dire en plus
monsieur le sénateur qu' il ne faut pas
que nous nous cachions derrière n'aurait
derrière la réalité nos réalités nos
appréciations vous avez une commune qui
se porte bien je la chance de la
connaître mais vous savez lippé richesse
côtoient lippert pauvreté en france et
nous n'avons pas trouvé d'autre réponse
que l'intercommunalité plus forte en
prenant bien évidemment
parce qu'il faut être prudent
1 comment dirais je
en tenant compte pardonnez moi mon
manque de phrases préparer de la densité
démographique pour éviter d'avoir des
intercommunautés 200 km mais je pense
aujourd'hui que la notion de bassin de
vie est une notion qui correspond à nos
citoyens et sur la question puisque
votre question essentielle porte sur la
démocratie je crois qu'il faut qu'une
religion ensemble surtout dans cette
haute assemblée que c'est le maire qui
représente la république jeu c'est lui
qui porte actes en tant qu'officier
ministériel et vous le savez bien c'est
la terre coverity qui porte
l'investissement les nouveaux services
nous allons avoir à réfléchir enfants
ensemble à cet avenir là et je ne crois
pas que ce sont des décisions qui
viennent d'en haut ces dons sont des
décisions qui viennent de l'observation
des territoires et je vous invite
monsieur le cam aux débats qui vont
venir parce que l'observation des
territoires nous apprend beaucoup et je
sais et je sais votre attachement au
territoire et à leur évolution pour la
réplique paroles et à monsieur gérard le
cam
je vous ai écouté avec beaucoup
d'attention en 1 la ministre est cher
collègue bretonne les communes vont
elles tenir le coup me dites vous
effectivement j'ai eu l'occasion de
proposer une faire une proposition de
loi dans cette assemblée il ya peu de
temps des battues qui avec moins d'1
milliard d'euros permettait d'augmenter
de manière très significative les moyens
de l'ensemble des communes rurales de
moins de vingt mille habitants
l'ensemble des sénateurs et sénatrices
sur les bancs ici partager cette idée
même si elle n'a pas été concrétisé et
je pense que les communes peuvent tenir
le coup et qu'il ne faut surtout pas
déséquilibrer cet équilibre qui existe
aujourd'hui entre communes et
intercommunalités nous avons besoin des
intercommunalités c'est vrai nous avons
besoin aussi des communes et des maires
qui ne soit pas demain des
administrateurs de politiques venues
d'en haut mais des maires de plein
exercice et c'est tout cela l'enjeu que
je veux soutenir ici au nom de l' de la
révolution française et de l'héritage
que nous devons tenir et je crois que
c'est quelque chose de très important
nous sommes plus de 36000 dans ce pays à
défendre cette idée des communes autour
desquels s'agglomèrent les personnes
s'identifient nos populations faites
attention à ne pas briser cela merci
merci où chacun avec la parole est un
monsieur joël labbé pour le groupe
écologiste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre chers collègues
territoires ruraux et décentralisation
ce thème est important en cette période
post électorale
nous nous devons de nous interroger sur
les signes qui nous ont été donnés
notamment par une part importante des
populations rurales traduisant le
sentiment de déclassement le sentiment
d'abandon de leur territoire il y va de
la cohésion sociale de la cohésion
nationale de la cohésion républicaine
de notre pays
c'est là un enjeu fondamental du nouvel
acte de la décentralisation nous allons
écrire prochainement en juillet 80 le 15
françois mitterrand déclarait la france
a eu besoin d'un pouvoir fort et
centralisé pour ce faire elle a
aujourd'hui besoin d'un pouvoir
décentralisé pour ne pas se défaire
c'était en 81 aussi pour nous
écologistes la nouvelle architecture
territoriale que vous nous soumettez
madame la ministre doit être en mesure
de nous donner des réponses adaptées aux
attentes des territoires des régions
compétences renforcées aux capacités
d'action accru bénéficiant d'une grande
autonomie financière
des intercommunalités renforcée elle
aussi couvrant des bassins de vie et
placé au coeur des dispositifs de
proximité
ces intercommunalités qui représente la
chance de survie de nombreuses communes
où le rôle du maire reste et doit rester
essentiels comme relais direct et
premiers interlocuteurs des citoyens ces
intercommunalités seront à l'avenir le
meilleur échelon pour exercer les
compétences sociales de proximité en
lieu et place des départements les
territoires ruraux ainsi organisé autour
des villes petites et moyennes seront au
centre des stratégies régionales les
campagnes seront à même de construire
leur propre projet de territoire moderne
et innovant l'agriculture historiquement
au coeur de la réalité qui se trouve
aujourd'hui à la croisée des chemins
pourra retrouver sa première fonction
alimentaire de proximité c'est donc des
régions fortes qui permettront ce retour
à l'équilibré à la complémentarité à la
solidarité entre métropole villes
petites et moyennes et territoires
ruraux mais pour cela il faudra à ces
régions des moyens financiers à la
hauteur des enjeux alors que la dotation
globale de fonctionnement est en baisse
le seul moyen de répondre à la nécessité
de solidarité et d'égalité des
territoires est de mettre en oeuvre une
péréquation forte et ambitieuse
alors madame la ministre j'en viens à ma
question quelle est la position du
gouvernement concernant l'élaboration
d'un système de péréquation autant
intrarégional qu'un ter régional je vous
remercie merci à vous chers collègues la
parole est à monsieur andré vallini
secrétaire d'état chargé de la réforme
territoriale
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur les inégalités de ressources
sont très forte entre nos territoires
vous avez raison cela s'explique par une
fiscalité injuste mais aussi par un
système de dotation trop inégalitaire
notre réponse d'un dock aller de pair
avec une politique d'égalité des
territoires notamment grâce à une
péréquation renforcer premières mesures
la révision des valeurs locatives
vous le savez elle a été engagée en
commençant par celle des locaux
professionnels c'est une oeuvre de
longue haleine pour les locaux
d'habitation l'article 74 de la lfr pour
2013 engage une expérimentation de cette
révision des valeurs locatives qui doit
être conduite fin 2014 début 2015 une
évaluation est prévue dans le cas dans
le rapport qui vous sera remis le 30
septembre 2015
deuxième mesure sur la péréquation et
les dotations ne devrait très ambitieux
en matière de solidarité entre les
territoires nous sommes favorables à une
réforme de la dgf sur deux années 2015
et 2016 avec marylise lebranchu et
christian eckert
nous y travaillons activement pour que
cette dgf soit plus juste l'enjeu est
considérable puisque la dgf ces 40
milliards d'euros dont 23 pour les
communes et le groupe le regroupement le
bloc communal les arbitrages ne sont pas
rendus mais nous sommes favorables avec
marylise lebranchu une progression très
sensible de ce qu'on appelle la
péréquation verticale dans la dgf c'est
à dire une hausse fort de la dotation de
solidarité urbaine qui représentait 1
milliard 5 en 2014 et de la dsr la
dotation de ce rite de solidarité rurale
qui représente un milliard cette année
avec un âge a programmé de haut sur
trois ans en dehors la dgf nous sommes
favorable aussi à la poursuite de
l'augmentation du smic pour qu'ils
passent de 570 millions d'euros à 780
millions d'euros enfin concernant les
régions
leur périmètre a grandi permettra
d'avoir une meilleure péréquation entre
les territoires favoriser ceux qui le
sont moins et nous sommes favorables à
ce que dès 2016 dans le cas des
nouvelles grandes régions que nous
sommes en train de mettre au point avec
le gouvernement c'est de la carte sera
soumise au parlement cet été la
péréquation soit plus forte je le répète
entre les territoires riches et ceux qui
le sont enfin dernier exemple sur la
péréquation marylise lebranchu a fait
voter une loi le 27 janvier la fameuse
loi nappe tam qui prévoit plus de
péréquation notamment au sein de la
métropole du grand paris et dans la
future métropole d'aix marseille
provence où vous voyez monsieur le
sénateur nous sommes très attentifs à
votre souci d'une plus grande solidarité
entre les territoires
merci pour la réplique à paroles est un
sujet elle la baie pour une minute mon
cher collègue
oui merci monsieur le ministre de votre
de votre réponse claire les choses sont
encore en chantier et le chantier et à
amener à terme
sur une chose importante qui fait débat
je ne suis pas je ne les ai pas dit dans
mon propos initial mais pour nous étant
donné l'importance que vont prendre les
intercommunalités il est évident que le
suffrage universel direct sera une
nécessité et cela rapidement je remercie
la parole est à monsieur jacques mézard
pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique social européen vers la
parole monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président madame monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est à la
demande du rds ce que la conférence des
présidents a accepté ce thème les
territoires ruraux et la réforme
territoriale
donc la question la question est de
savoir comment vous entendez concilier
la fusion des régions avec l'éloignement
des métropoles de nombre de territoires
avec le besoin de proximité d'autant
qu'en même temps vous proposer la
suppression des conseils généraux c'est
quand même assez surréaliste comme type
de proposition vous savez que dans nos
territoires ce qui est de plus en plus
prégnant c'est le sentiment d'abandon
vous avez ce matin dans le journal la
montagne monsieur le ministre wallon dit
que tous les parlementaires étaient
d'accord pour la fusion par exemple
rhône alpes auvergne je tiens à vous
dire que ce n'est pas vrai car je suis
là en face de vous vous avez aussi
affirmé que les moyens de communication
change les distances se raccourcissent
avec votre projet
la préfecture d'aurillac je suis
président de l'agglomération sera à
10h52 aller retour de la métropole
régionale à plus de huit heures aller
retour par le train et monsieur monsieur
le ministre vous avez vous avez dit
aussi que vous avez reconnu qu'il n'y
aurait plus pour de petits départements
comme les nôtres qui intéresse peut bien
que vous soyez toujours président de
conseil général eh bien vous avez dit
que nous n'aurions plus que deux
conseillers régionaux sur 150
donc il y aura un ump un ps même plus à
peine d'aller voter
peut-être deux ump d'ailleurs mes chers
collègues mais en tout cas il ne faut
pas dire dans ces conditions que vous
vous préoccupez de ces territoires dits
ruraux dans lesquelles il ya aussi des
zones urbaines et je crois que là il y a
une véritable difficulté et nous avons
besoin de véritables réponses parce que
cette réforme il n'y aura pas d'économie
il n'y aura pas de proximité et vous
avez in fine et l'assurance qu'en ce qui
concerne les départements elle ne verra
pas le jour merci la parole est à
monsieur andré vallini secrétaire d'état
chargé de la réforme territoriale
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président mais art je ne suis plus
président du conseil général j'ai
démissionné mon successeur serait élu la
semaine prochaine première précision
deuxième chose concernant les
parlementaires j'ai voulu dire les
députés à la journaliste elle due par
extension parler des parlementaires tous
les députés d'auvergne sont favorables à
la fusion avec rhône-alpes les députés y
compris monsieur chassaigne et notamment
aussi il n'est pas parlementaire le
maire clermont ferrand je pense que la
réforme territoriale que nous préparons
avec marylise lebranchu à la demande du
premier ministre vise trois objectifs
plus de clarté plus de compétitivité et
plus de proximité monsieur le président
mais par la clarté parce que notre
organisation territoriale a vieilli elle
devenu complexe les citoyens ne s'y
retrouvent plus et c'est une exigence
démocratique que d'avoir une
organisation territoriale plus clair où
le citoyen puisse savoir qui fait quoi
qui finance quoi deuxième objectif la
compétitivité des grandes régions plus
grande part la taille plus grande aussi
par le poids démographique par le poids
économique seront mieux à même de jouer
leur rôle dans la compétition
internationale entre territoires entre
grandes régions européennes
avec les compétences que nous allons
leur conférer notamment le développement
économique l'aide aux entreprises l'aide
à l'innovation les transports y compris
les routes ces régions ces grandes
régions françaises seront mieux armées
je le répète dans la compétition
européenne voire mondiale enfin la
proximité c'est votre préoccupation
c'est aussi la mienne j'ai moi aussi
dans mon département monsieur le
sénateur des territoires ruraux qui
s'organise depuis 20 ans autour
d'intercommunalité qui grandissent qui
ont déjà grandi à la suite de la
dernière loi qui vont grandir encore
avec des dérogations pour les
territoires de montagne de ceux de 20000
habitants sera sans doute aménagés dans
les territoires les plus enclavées et
les moins peuplés mais ce sont les
intercommunalités qui ont tout changé la
pertinence de l'échelon départemental
est remise en cause par la montée en
puissance des intercommunalités jean
pierre bel l'a dit il faut supprimer les
conseils généraux à condition de ne pas
les remplacer par rien alors nous
réfléchissons avec d'autres à une
fédération d'intercommunalité un conseil
des communautés à une assemblée de
communauté cette idée remonte aux
rapports mauroy de 2000
et non pas encore des structures il
s'agirait simplement de regrouper les
communautés de communes pour qu'elles
s'organisent entre elles et qu'elles
fassent jouer la solidarité entre celles
qui sont favorisés et celles qui le sont
moins nous avons quatre ans pour
réfléchir au remplacement des
conseillers généraux par ces structures
de solidarité territoriale
merci pour la réplique à paroles et à
monsieur jacques mézard merci monsieur
le président inutile de vous dire que je
ne suis pas convaincu par les
explications monsieur le ministre alors
nous sommes dans une situation monsieur
le ministre rouler davantage de
simplicité de clarification nous l'avons
aujourd'hui ici même d'ailleurs j'ai
voté contre le rétablissement de la
clause de compétence générale il ya
quelques mois aujourd'hui vous proposez
linverse c'est assez original comme
cohérence et je crois que oui monsieur
il n'en reste pas moins que vous n'avez
pas répondu à la réalité a au fond de la
question cette proximité à partir du
moment où vous avez des métropoles
régionales extrêmement éloignées où vous
supprimez les conseillers vous nous
parlez de regroupements
d'intercommunalités
je suis président d'agglomération je
sais ce que c'est j'ai proposé y signer
eux mêmes au nom de mon groupe un
système pour élire les conseillers
départementaux sur la base des
intercommunalités vont y est opposée il
n'y a pas longtemps il ya moins d'un an
donc là aussi contradictions ce dont
nous avons besoin c'est d'un objectif
clair lisible et ça nous ne l'avons pas
encore trouvé c'est ce que je tenais à
vous dire merci la parole est à monsieur
françois noël buffet pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire
mais chez le président mam le ministre
chen ministre chers collègues parfois 10
milliards parfois 12 parfois 25 voici
des estimations qui varient du simple au
double des soi-disant des économies que
devrait porter en son sein votre réforme
pourquoi tant d'écart pourquoi ces
chiffres comment avez vous pu établir
ces chiffres
cartels sont bien aujourd'hui les
questions que se posent de l'ensemble
des élus locaux de notre nation
il ya deux réponses possibles la
première bien sûr c'est celle que vous
n'avez pas réalisé d'étude d'impact en
tous les cas si vous l'avez fait vous
l'avez pas rendu public et si vous
n'avez pas rendu public en tous les cas
à la connaissance des parlementaires que
nous sommes c'est que vous avez quelques
raisons de la cacher pourquoi cela si
elle est bonne si ces chiffres doivent
être précis et que vous avez des
chiffres précis pourquoi ne pas nous les
donner pour que nous puissions en
débatte clairement la deuxième hypothèse
monsieur ou madame le ministre c'est que
vous avez dû revoir votre copie en
urgence compte tenu des réactions qu'a
provoqué les déclarations que vous avez
fait et les annonces notamment au sein
de votre à la majorité gouvernementale
et singulièrement en annonçant la
suppression des départements tout ceci
pourrait être propos d'opposition sauf
qu il apparaît que l' agence moody's qui
a étudié la réforme que vous avez
présenté et que vous soutenez est en
train de battre en brèche tous les
propos que vous tenez
c'est sans surprise qu'elle confirme
notre point de vue votre projet de
réforme territoriale ne serait réduire
sérieusement les coûts supportés par nos
collectivités territoriales d'ailleurs
moody's constate un risque d'aggravation
est je cite de la dépense locale et
confirme que ce projet de réforme
n'aidera pas les collectivités
territoriales à atteindre leurs
objectifs budgétaires
ces mesures annoncées ne faut que
redistribuer les coûts vers d'autres
organes décentralisés
elle insiste également sur des points
particuliers concernant les salaires
voilà la situation des collectivités
locales demain comment vont elles faire
devant cette pression que vous leur
apportez cette réforme qui coûtera
encore plus cher alors monsieur le
ministre madame le ministre comment
allez-vous donner aux collectivités
locales la capacité de pouvoir faire
face à toutes ces augmentations que vous
imposez après avoir tellement prélever
d'argent auprès des français sans jamais
leur permettre de pouvoir continuer
d'être sérieusement au service de la
nation et de faire des choses sérieuses
et pouvoir ces collectivités continuent
d'investir telles qu'elles ont fait
jusqu'à maintenant merci merci mon cher
collègue la parole et à monsieur andré
vallini secrétaire d'état chargé de la
réforme territoriale
merci monsieur le président de l'aim et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur
d'abord cette réforme elle est faite
pour je les dis au président on mézard
plus de clarté dans les compétences
plus de compétitivité pour les régions
plus de proximité avec les
intercommunalités
permettra-t-elle de réaliser des
économies oui bien sûr à long terme
dans les premiers mois les premières
années certains disent je crois qu'ils
ont réseau que le transfert des
personnels va coûter un peu notamment
entre les départements et les régions
mais pour une fois si on essayait
d'échapper au court termisme au court
termisme à la vision à courte vue des
politiques l'on peut mener des réformes
que l'on fait cette réforme c'est une
réforme structurelle et dieu sait si
l'ump appelle des réformes structurelles
et quand on demande à l'ump laquelle
voulez vous en premier vous répondez
toujours la réforme territoriale on l'a
fait cette réforme on fait une réforme
structurelle qui va marquer
l'organisation de la république pour 30
ou 50 ans et dont les effets dont les
effets financiers se feront sentir à 5 à
10 ans entre 5 et 10 ans alors les
économies évidemment j'ai à votre
disposition le rapport queyranne sur
l'aide au développement économique le
rapport malvy lambert sur toutes les
économies possibles que l'on peut faire
dans la gestion territoriale des
rapports de l' ocde
des rapports de différents organismes
d'état ou parapublic qui lie tous qu'ils
disent tous la même chose des économies
d'échelle sont possibles la
mutualisation permet aussi de faire des
économies ou feraient passer une note
chiffrée de 3 pages qui vous montrera à
quel point ces économies pourront être
réalisées si tout le monde évidemment se
mettent à se mette au travail en termes
d'économies de gestion d'échelle de
mutualisation quant aux chiffres que
vous avancez reprenons ce que j'ai moi
même indiqué monsieur le sénateur le
budget global des collectivités locales
ces 250 milliards d'euros communes
intercommunalités salut quatre communes
départements régions 250 milliards
d'euros six sur dix ans après avoir
réformé l'ensemble des strates et pas
seulement fusionner les régions on n'est
pas capable d'obtenir 5 % d'économie
c'est à dire 12 milliards d'euros mieux
vaut changer de métier la politique
c'est du volontarisme monsieur le
sénateur
merci pour la réplique à paroles et à
monsieur françois noël buffet monsieur
le ministre
nous sommes pour la réforme pour la
réforme structurelle de nos
collectivités nous l'avons porté ici en
2010 et vous l'avez combattu fortement
en ce qui concerne la clarté elle ne
saute pas aux yeux permettez moi de vous
dire qu'aujourd'hui les réactions dans
tous les toutes les instances qui a fait
jusque là dessus sont quasiment toutes
unanimes pour dire qu'il n'y a pas de
cohérence dans le projet que vous
présentez qu'il est segmenté et qu'il ne
donne pas de lignes parfaitement clair
en ce qui concerne la compétitivité je
vous rappelle qu'en 2010 nous avons posé
la question de la spécialisation des
différentes institutions enfin des
différentes collectivités locales que
vous êtes opposés parce que nous
pensions qu effectivement il fallait
être compétitif et donner aux
collectivités un rôle particulier pour
être efficace vous l'avez combattu à
l'époque en ce qui concerne la proximité
pas de leçon nous avons mis en place le
conseiller territorial qui ancrait le
conseil régional sur un territoire
déterminé qui rapprochait le département
et la région rhône alpes et la région
pardon ronald bien sûr parce que c'est
la nôtre mais en même temps mais en même
temps vous l'avez également combattu
vous précipitant de l'élection dépendra
public pour le supprimer alors en fait
peut-être qu'à terme vous y reviendrez
et je pense que ce serait une bonne
chose on pourra même le voter merci la
parole était monsieur à mairie de
montesquiou pour le groupe union des
démocrates et indépendants us et
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la réforme territoriale est une
nécessité
mais votre projet tel que présenté
inquiète le monde rural et ses élus car
dimension urbaine leur apparaît
prioritaire
comment avez vous pu concevoir et
décider une nouvelle organisation
territoriale
unilatéralement de plus celle-ci ne
prend pas en compte la diversité des
territoires à peine la carte des opci
adopté avec un seuil de 5000 habitants
vous imposez ex abrupto autant d'actes
communalité un nouveau seuil minimal de
20 mille habitants des six fin 2016
la compétence sociale pour les conseils
généraux dans les zones rurales se
résume souvent à des guichets et la
majorité des intercommunalités ne peut
supporter cette charge avant tout
tiendrez-vous compte des bassins de vie
quelle sera la place des services de
l'état l'état pourrait-il reprendre une
partie des compétences sociales via
c'est que services déconcentrés
quel sera l'avenir des chambres
consulaires échos des préoccupations du
monde rural pour l'heure il n'est
question que du découpage des régions la
question centrale des compétences est
élu des ailes et termine pourtant les
domaines et les moyens d'action
les territoires ruraux qui portent en
eux un grand potentiel de développement
sont aujourd'hui fragilisée la menace de
voir disparaître les solidarités entre
les populations urbaines et rurales
s'accentue en contradiction avec le
principe républicain fondamental
d'égalité des chances
monsieur le ministre quels sont les
objectifs précis et argumenté du
gouvernement pour les territoires
o qui se sentent de plus en plus
abandonnés merci la parole est à mme
marylise lebranchu
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur avait manqué ce coup c'est vrai
que
j'apprécie beaucoup le tour de votre
question qui était extrêmement
structurée vous avez raison de parler du
sentiment d'abandon on en a souvent
parlé au cours de nos derniers débats
vous avez raison de parler territoire
est compétent sur cartes et compétences
et le 18 juin donc moi-même avec andré
vallini déposons un texte sur les
compétences pendant que le ministre de
l'intérieur déposera le texte ce qui est
de droit ni bien évidemment sur la carte
des régions mais juste quelques points
parce que le temps nous est compté
vous dites les intercommunalités 20000
habitants ce sera difficile il y a une
clause de revoyure dans la loi de 2010
que nous avons appliqué parce que la
continuité républicaine est nécessaire
et cette clause de revoyure va nous
permettre de poser la question de
l'intercommunalité plus grande en
prenant en compte bien évidemment la
ruralité en particulier puisque la
densité d'habitants au kilomètre carré
qui sera un des critères qui sera donnée
aux préfets pour réunir la sdc y portera
sur essentiellement le monde rural et la
montagne donc nous prenons en compte
cette difficulté mais quand vous
regardez bien le sentiment d'abandon
quand vous regardez un certain nombre d
quand vous lisez pardon un certain
nombre d'études extrêmement bien
documenté on voit que ce sentiment
d'abandon est né d'une série de dix
grandes difficultés fermeture de la
poste fermeture de la perception
fermeture de l'école absence de service
et petit à petit un sentiment
effectivement de difficultés d'accès au
service des entreprises publiques et aux
services de l'état et nous ne voulons
pas andré vallini et moi porter cette
responsabilité là même si je reconnais
je reconnais à l'ancienne majorité la
difficulté de garder toutes les recettes
perception par exemple donc nous avons à
repenser ensemble l'accès aux services
publics parce que vous avez parfaitement
raison en particulier sur un point il
n'y a pas d'égalité des possibles en
france et notre souhait c'est de
répondre à l'égalité des possibles et
l'égalité des possibles ça passe
effectivement par une organisation
territoriale mais ça passe par la
péréquation andré vallini a expliqué ça
passe aussi par un travail
en commun sont notre organisation
territoriale pour que chaque enfant de
france est taxée au possible ce qui
n'est pas aujourd'hui le cas on
continuera ce débat monsieur le sénateur
lors de l'automne je pense mais c'est
vrai que je partage votre souci nous ne
sommes pas forcément d'accord sur les
solutions qui ont été proposées mais
rendez-nous au moins 7 grâce là entre
guillemets parce que je suis
républicaine le débat parlementaire sera
totalement ouvert comme il l'a été la
dernière fois
la réplique à part le thème générique
d'une moto sioux
ministre pour le ton posé et ouvert de
votre réponse qui m'interdit de la
qualifiée d' autoritarisme jacobins
nous sommes tous soucieux de l'égalité
des chances
aussi on est un peu surpris et
quelquefois scandalisé lorsqu'on voit
les dotations de l'état à des zones
urbaines particulièrement dense économie
les zones rurales il y a une façon de
trouver cette égalité des chances c'est
le numérique il doit y avoir un effort
particulier sur le numérique et pour
éviter des querelles gauche droite moi
je vous propose 20 le ministre qui est
un audit par un cabinet indépendant qui
décide ce qui est souhaitable et que
droite et gauche et centre se réunissent
pour trouver ce qui est possible on doit
pas avoir d'affrontement politique sur
un sujet aussi profond aussi important
pour notre pays
la parole est à madame frédérique
espagnac pour le groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
la réforme territoriale engagée d'un
sommet décisif pour l'avenir de notre
pays nos territoires
l'organisation de la supply chain et la
simplification du maillage territorial
français apparaît depuis des années
comme tout à fait nécessaire autant sur
les bancs de la droite que de la gauche
à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
j'observe qu'à l'heure de la réforme il
y a beaucoup moins de villa velléités
d'un coup pourtant permettez moi de
rappeler mes chers collègues qu'un large
consensus s'était dégagé ici au sénat au
moment du vote du rapport raffarin
cratère géant 2013 qui préconisait déjà
cette simplification administrative
cette fusion des régions permettra
d'accroître la puissance notamment
économique de promouvoir l'emploi comme
mes collègues l'ont dit et la cohésion
territoriale
tous les gouvernements précédents ont
évoqué la nécessité d'une telle réforme
mais c'est ce président de la république
et ce gouvernement qui ont le courage de
s'y attaquer la réforme est difficile
certes mais elle est nécessaire et nous
le savons tous c'est parce que nous
voulons que cette réforme soit une
réforme de structure dans le paysage
territorial français qu'elle marque une
étape décisive pour nos territoires et
que nous venons aussi vous faire part
des inquiétudes que nous saurons
cesse-t-on chaque semaine dans nos
départements madame la ministre depuis
les annonces du président de la
république relayée ensuite par le
premier ministre le gouvernement les
interrogations des élus locaux que nous
sommes se multiplient par qui tu
particulièrement dans les territoires
ruraux ces territoires vous laisse aller
mieux que personne la ministre souffre
depuis un moment d'un sentiment de
relégation et ont été particulièrement
touchés par la crise que nous traversons
il faut donc faire particulièrement
attention à ne pas accentuer ce
sentiment d'abandon par les aime qui
démentait ce qu il ya quelques minutes
en donnant l'impression qu'on éloigne
encore un peu plus ces territoires des
centres de décision nous connaissions
l'attachement du gouvernement à la
préservation et au développement de la
ruralité mais il faut que cela se
traduise dans des actes et dans des
mesures qui seront prises dans ces deux
projets de loi dans mon département des
pyrénées atlantiques les attentes sont
fortes au pays basque tout d'abord à un
territoire identitaire cette réforme
ouvrir des perspectives intéressantes et
je vous en remercie mme la ministre dans
une approche territoriale de solidarité
de rural parle urbain en mer par contre
il en va de même pour les zones de
montagne néanmoins cela concerne
beaucoup d'autres territoires sur ceux
sur notre pays dans sa tribune publiée
le 3 juin 2014 dans la presse régionale
le président de la république a très
légitimement affirmer que des
adaptations seront prévus pour des zones
de montagne et territoires faiblement
peuplé c'est une nécessité absolue dans
les zones qui font qu'ils font excusez
moi dans ces zones qui font déjà face à
de nombreux risques de disparition des
services publics de proximité avec des
menaces de fermeture de son poteau ou de
gendarmerie il est important que le
gouvernement précise ses intentions et
donc madame la ministre je vous demande
plus précisément de nous en faire part
merci merci la parole est madame
marylise lebranchu oui merci monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice espagnac
c'est vrai que sur place avec vous on a
pu constater c'est ce que ce sentiment
d'abandon n'est pas une invention de
notre part qui avait une vraie demande
d'accès aux services publics est
d'ailleurs la première chose qu'il faut
redire ici c'est que dans ce projet de
loi comme dans l'ensemble de la
politique du gouvernement l'action
publique le service public sont au
centre de nos préoccupations et que nous
y tenons parce que moi j'entends que la
réforme est difficile j'entends
l'opposition
à avoir des mots un peu durs mais je lui
rappelle que l'action publique le
service public au coeur de la république
ont été mis aussi en danger à d'autres
moments donc il faut que nous soyons
très serein et très apaisé sur cette
question de l'action publique sur le cas
que vous dites par exemple est ce qu'il
est possible d'avoir une
intercommunalité suffisamment forte qui
répond dans l'histoire la langue à la
culture sans doute est ce qu'il est
possible d'allier cette reconnaissance
d'un passé qui rend plus forts avec des
volontés de développement d'ouverture au
monde d'ouverture aux autres sans aucun
doute donc sur ce point nous aurons
débat et je pense qu'il sera intéressant
mais nous ajouterons un côté avec ce qui
a été déjà proposée mais que nous allons
renforcer qu'il est indispensable que
dans nos départements ruraux nous ayons
des séries maison de service public que
nous soyons en capacité de les regrouper
pour que le citoyen sage où quand et
avec quels moyens il peut se rendre vers
quelqu'un qui aura l'obligation de
répondre à toutes ces questions
concernant l'action publique parce que
l'action publique elle est une elle est
exercée au nom de l'état par les
collectivités depuis la décentralisation
mais elle doit rester une même si et je
vous la corde avec beaucoup
d'appréciation philosophique et
sociologique
il ne faut jamais rayé l'histoire et
enfin ce que je trouvais intéressant
dans des zones comme la vôtre c'est
l'extrême j'ai envie de dire acharnement
des élus à dire que chaque enfant de
votre territoire doit avoir accès à tous
les services et au cours de débats c'est
sur ces questions que andré besnier et
moi nous nous engageons à répondre
merci pour la réplique parole de thomas
daum espagnac merci monsieur le
président madame et messieurs vous
remercie pour votre réponse nous
comprenons parfaitement latrines et 6,6
de cette réorganisation politique
administrative de la france cela se
justifiait la fois sur le plan
démocratique l'architecturé actuelle ait
tant de mal comprise les citoyens sur
sur le plan économique aussi les acteurs
attendent une organisation simplifiée
pour faciliter la production les
déplacements enfin sur le plan financier
en participant à la maîtrise des
dépenses publiques comme nous l'avons
dit moi-même en l'ensemble du groupe
socialiste nous voulons engager nous
engager dans cette réforme ils vont le
faire avec détermination mais mal
galement avec franchise pour que le
travail du sénat représentant les
collectivités locales soient
constructifs et permettent à cette
réforme d'être bénéfique pour toutes les
parties de notre territoire et même
surtout pour les plus reculés les plus
fragiles car nous pensons que ce profond
changement doit être l'occasion de
repenser la proche des services publics
dans les territoires ruraux vous venez
de le dire la mutiler la mutualisation
et la modernisation des compétences doit
être engagée il est temps pour l'avenir
de ces territoires ruraux qui sont une
chance pour notre pays identifiés
l'itinérance des services de notifier
des réseaux existants notamment en
matière de santé d'amplifier la
politique volontariste de développement
et de transformation des maisons de
service public comme vous l'avez dit ou
encore de finaliser leur couverture par
le très haut débit ce qui est très
important aujourd'hui c'est question
doit être doit faire partie intégrante
de notre réflexion à tous au moment de
repenser l'organisation administrative
de nos institutions et la répartition de
leurs compétences au premier élément de
réponse semble aller dans le bon sens
madame la ministre je m'en réjouis car
ces territoires ruraux ne doivent pas et
ne peuvent pas être oubliés dans le
cadre de cette réforme territoriale il
en va de l'avenir mais également
la parole et à monsieur françois appuyé
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
seul président madame messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues je cite
les mots exacts prononcés par le
président de la république il ya moins
de cinq mois lors de ses voeux aux
corréziens les départements gardent leur
utilité pour assurer la cohésion sociale
et la solidarité territoriale et je ne
suis donc pas favorable à leur
suppression pure et simple comme
certains le réclament car des
territoires ruraux perdrait en qualité
de vie sans d'ailleurs généré
d'économies supplémentaires si l'on y
supprimait le département fin de
citation voilà un diagnostic qui me
paraît largement partagé dans ce
contexte comment comprendre le projet de
réforme territoriale dans les
dispositions n'ont cessé d'être
contredite par les membres de votre
gouvernement est décrié d'ailleurs pas
rebonds nombre des membres de votre
majorité dans nos territoires pour une
grande majorité d'élus et pour nos
concitoyens toutes sensibilités
confondues
cette réforme semble relever de
l'opportunisme politique plutôt que de
la satisfaction de l'intérêt général il
est question de reporter les élections
départementales et régionales
comment voulez vous que nos concitoyens
n'analyse pas cette volonté par la peur
manifeste d'un énième revers annoncé
pour votre majorité après avoir
d'ailleurs modifier le scrutin
départemental pour influer a priori sur
son résultat vous affirmez que ce projet
de réforme territoriale vise à réduire
le millefeuille administratif mais dans
les faits n'en sera rien puisque les
mesures prévues se limite à notre
connaissance a supprimé la clause
générale de compétence fraîchement
rétabli après l'avoir manifestement mais
massivement combattu en 2010 pour la
suppression du département co qui vit je
prendrai un seul exemple celui des
routes anciennement nationale qui ont
été départementalisée que vont-elles
devenir vont-elles être régionalisées
que vont surtout devenir les agents
territoriaux en charge de la gestion de
ces infrastructures
et puis enfin après nous interroger sur
la cohérence de votre proposition
la suppression du département conduit
nécessairement à vous interroger sur
l'avenir des représentants des
collectivités locales territoriales que
nous sommes et par là même sur l'avenir
de notre propre institution merci le
parole et à monsieur vallini
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur je suis conseiller général et
je sais depuis 22 ans maintenant à quel
point les conseils généraux ont été
utiles depuis les grandes lois de
décentralisation je sais à quel point
chaque président de conseil général
qu'elles soient de droite ou de gauche
a pris à coeur et missions qui lui ont
été confiées par ses lois mauroy de fer
à quel point chaque conseiller général
dans son canton est investi dans sa
mission qu'il accomplit avec beaucoup de
dévouement et souvent avec passion il ya
un attachement très fort entre le
conseiller général son territoire la
population de ce territoire je sais tout
ça je le vis moi même depuis 22 ans je
le répète mais depuis les lois de
décentralisation justement les choses
ont changé la montée en puissance des
intercommunalités c'est ce que je
répondais aux présidents mézard tout à
l'heure a remis en cause la pertinence
de l'échelon départemental
aujourd'hui les communes sont regroupées
elles vont le faire encore davantage
demain les intercommunalités vont
grandir c'est prévu dans la loi que nous
vous présenterons cet été
elles passent déjà des conventions entre
elles pour éviter certaines compétences
à la plage du département moi même dans
mon département de l'isère il ya des
communautés d'agglomération et de
communes qui par-dessus crosser générale
ont passé des conventions ont noué des
partenariats en matière de transport de
développement économique de gestion du
foncier de logement le conseil général
garde toute sa pertinence c'est vrai est
ce que le prison la république avait dit
à tulle en matière de solidarité sociale
lorsque nous aurons voté la loi sur les
grandes régions plus puissante et sur
les intercommunalités plus grandes aussi
nous aurons quatre ans pour voir comment
transmettre les compétences sociales des
conseils généraux aux régions aux
intercommunalités
certains proposent même à l'état je
pense au rsa et aux caisses
d'allocations familiales le débat est
ouvert nous aurons quatre ans notamment
au sénat pour réfléchir ensemble à la
meilleure façon d'assurer cette
transition vers l'année 2020 donc voilà
je veux vous rassurer de ce point de vue
les conseils généraux jouent un rôle
très utile en matière sociale il n'est
pas question de remettre en cause des
politiques de cohésion sociale la paix à
la pch le rsa et encore moins l'enfance
en danger ou les concessions font un
travail remarquable
nous aurons le temps de voir à qui
confier ses compétences majeures dans la
cohésion sociale de notre pays merci
monsieur françois pinet
ministre je ne voudrais pas de la minute
qui m'est donnée pour vous poser une
autre question mais je voulais tout de
même attiré votre attention sur le fait
qu'une telle réforme touche à la vie
démocratique de notre pays telle qu'elle
fonctionne de manière ancestrale nous ne
ferons pas cette réforme là uniquement
entre élus il faut que nos concitoyens y
adhèrent et monsieur oui je vous donnais
tout simplement le sentiment certes peu
scientifique que je ressens en étant
sénateur du cher département rural c'est
que après les diminutions de dotation
après les
prises de frais supplémentaires
qu'engendre en particulier la réforme
des temps scolaires
cette réforme est mal partie pour être
susciter une adhésion chez nos
concitoyens si la parole est à monsieur
vincent eblé pour vous que le soliste
monsieur le président madame monsieur le
ministre annoncée par le premier
ministre nous saluons l'objectif du
gouvernement d'entamer une réforme
territoriale
cette réforme nécessaire pour optimiser
la conduite des politiques publiques
suscite des interrogations notamment les
clés disparition annoncée des conseils
généraux au profil région renforcer les
métropoles et des intercommunalités si
la capacité de reprise leurs compétences
par les métropoles et les grandes
intercommunalités ne semble pas poser de
difficultés majeures pour les zones très
denses nous sommes interrogatif à
l'égard des territoires à densité
moyenne ou faible dit ruraux et
périurbains
souligné dans le rapport à fin
krattinger le département par ses
compétences de proximité et le premier
échelon de la décentralisation il
possède une forte capacité fonctionnelle
d'instance de cohésion sociale insertion
dépendance handicap protection de
l'enfance en danger ainsi que d'instance
irremplaçable d'expression des besoins
spécifiques de la ruralité assurant une
péréquation de fait entre ville et
campagne il a été notamment le
fédérateur des intercommunalités au
profit desquelles il a exercé une
fonction dj ries le conseil général est
l'interlocuteur naturel des mères qui
estime que le département présente un
intérêt majeur pour leur territoire avec
la perspective de la suppression de cet
échelon les débats qui s'ouvriront dans
les prochains jours doivent permettre de
trouver les bons outils de l'action
publique pour prendre en considération
le devenir de ces territoires ruraux
néanmoins cette notion de ruralité
paraître peu précises à titre d'exemple
la nature du département dont je suis
l'élu la seine et marne en fait un
territoire hétérogène avec une large
zone ouest de densité moyenne aux
fonctions métropolitaines avéré pôle de
roissy ville nouvelle de marne la vallée
et de sénart agglomération préfecture
autour de melun et des territoires à
l'est dont la densité de population est
beaucoup plus faible et où la reprise
des politiques publiques conduites par
les conseils généraux semblent
extrêmement délicate par les outils dont
disposent les communes et les
intercommunalités de faible taille avec
cette mixité au sein d'un même
département comment qualifier la seine
et marne la question se pose dans les
mêmes termes pour toutes les zones
périurbaines en périphérie des
métropoles et des grandes
intercommunalités la disparition des
conseils généraux marquerait une perte
de dynamique pour ces territoires il
convient donc de trouver le bon échelon
la bonne répartition des compétences
pour leur permettre de conserver une
réelle dynamique de développement nous
savons que le gouvernement est très
attentif problématique des territoires à
faible densité ainsi nous souhaiterions
connaître vos intentions dans le projet
de loi à venir la parole était monsieur
andré vallini
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur et blé vous savez de quoi vous
parlez puisque vous présidez avec
beaucoup d'efficacité et
d'investissement personnel le conseil
général de seine-et-marne et je vais
reprendre les propos que je tenais à
l'endroit de monsieur pillés à l'instant
pour vous dire que nous devons réfléchir
ensemble comme vous le suggérez
parlement gouvernement élus
départementaux avec l'adf notamment et
son président claudy lebreton nous
devons réfléchir
en faisant preuve d'esprit de
responsabilité d'intelligence collective
et puis aussi de sens des réalités nous
devons réfléchir à l'avenir de l'échelon
départemental
la plupart des grands pays européens en
fait une réforme pour réduire le nombre
d'échelons dans leur organisation
territoriale la france
et le dernier pays à avoir autant
d'échelons les communes le bloc communal
ce n'est pas tout à fait la même chose
que les communes c'est-à-dire les
syndicats intercommunaux et les
syndicats de pays sur les syndicats
intercommunaux un seul chiffre il ya
encore 13400 syndicats intercommunaux
notamment les sivom et les civils 13400
syndicats intercommunaux dont 5800 sont
compris dans le périmètre d'un opci
pourquoi ne pas faire absorber ces
syndicats par la communauté de communes
ou d'agglomérations dans lesquelles ils
sont compris donc les communes les
syndicats de communes les syndicats de
pays les départements les régions il
faut simplifier rationaliser ce paysage
administratif territorial il faut faire
monter en puissance des
intercommunalités c'est déjà le cas à
grandir les régions et comme vous le
dites concernant la politique de
solidarité notamment en direction des
personnes les plus fragiles de la
société que même les conseils généraux
il faut que nous trouvions le bon
réglage le bon niveau est ce que ce
seront les communautés de communes a
grandi les métropoles sans doute les
communautés d'agglomération aussi le
problème se pose vous avez raison
d'aller dans les départements où dans
les zones de certains départements qui
ne sont ni tout à fait urbaine ni tout à
fait rural gilles et même dans mon
département l'agglomération grenobloise
mais dès qu'on s'éloigne à 40 ou 50 km
avant d'arriver dans la montagne très
isolées très reculées il ya des zones
intermédiaires nous avons quatre ans
pour savoir quel est le meilleur niveau
pour faire jouer la solidarité entre les
territoires favoriser ceux qui sont
moins notamment ceux auxquels vous
faites allusion et qui provoque chez
vous un souci tout à fait légitime sur
le sénateur monsieur blé très rapidement
s'il vous plaît oui merci monsieur le
ministre merci en particulier de nous
indiquer que vous souhaitez une
élaboration collective nous y sommes
évidemment prêts et même en appétit par
rapport à ce travail je voudrais vous
dire que il ne me semble pas qu'il
puisse y avoir une solution et qu'il
faudra trouver dans la loi une forme de
souplesse qui permettent une adaptation
en fonction de la réalité territoriale
notre français fait de territoire
extrêmement divers et il faudra trouver
des solutions adaptées à la réalité
particulière de chacun de ces
territoires évidemment comme président
d'un départements de la grande couronne
francilienne
vie cette différenciation des
territoires quotidiennement il faudra
que la réforme qui s'engagent répondre à
cette réalité particulière en tout cas
j'y serai particulièrement vigilant
merci la parole est à monsieur philippe
adnot pour la réunion administrative de
sénateurs de ses gants sur l'iss d'aucun
groupe je vous remercie monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je suis
très intrigué attiré intrigué comment un
président de conseil général peut-il
être aussi opposé à l'existence des
départements et parfois avec des propos
extrêmement violent je vous rappelle que
vous avez dit il faut les vider de leur
substance
comment peut-on présidé pendant dix ans
et ne pas avoir la passion de son
territoire et ne pas savoir comment on a
enrichit considérablement l'action
départementale
vous affirmez une baisse de la dépense
publique de 17 milliards mais vous savez
que c'est faux vous savez pertinemment
que c'est faux mon département
représente un demi pour cent des budgets
des départements ce que vous annoncez
voudrait dire que il y aurait 85
millions d'euros d'économies à faire
dans le conseil général de l'aube vous
savez que c'est faux et que ce n'est pas
possible et non seulement il n'y aura
pas baisse de la dépense publique il y
aura augmentation de la dépense publique
et je vais y revenir vous voulez
transférer les routes aux régions mer il
va falloir constituer les états-majors
régionaux parce qu'ils n'en n'ont pas et
il ne manquera pas un seul travailleur
dans sur les routes départementales
parce que nous avons qui misait
totalement l'organisation depuis la
décentralisation ou l'état nous a
redonné les personnels et avec une
grande maîtrise du nombre d'emplois et
croyez moi c'est pas dans les régions
qu'on arrivera à terre la même
régulation des emplois vous voulez
mettre les transports scolaires au aux
régions à quatre ou cinq cents
kilomètres on va faire le détail des
transports scolaires dans les communes
ben je vous souhaite bien du plaisir
c'est de la dentelle les transports
scolaires et il faut savoir tous les
matins s'il ya du verglas ou s'il n'a
pas si le carré peut circuler et vous
n'y arriverez pas en faisant avec les
régions alors voilà aujourd'hui quand
une région veut construire un lycée en
même temps qu'un collège ça arrive dans
un département ben c'est pas la région
qui construit
département qui construit pour le compte
de la région parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
services et donc vous allez produire un
nombre incalculable d'état major au
niveau régional et je vous garantis que
la dépense publique vous y en ait pas
encore arrivé madame lebranchu a annoncé
que s'ils ont supprimé la clause de
compétence générale ça ferait faire 35 %
d'économies dans les budgets des
conseils généraux il faut vraiment ne
rien connaître au budget pour pouvoir
dire des sottises pareil voilà je
voudrais vous dire monsieur le ministre
que moi j'ai commencé à faire les
comparaisons entre les régimes
indemnitaires des conseils régionaux et
des conseils départementaux
vous allez avoir une augmentation de
plus de 15 % de la masse salariale sans
compter l'augmentation du nombre de
fonctionnaires parce que les régions
n'ont pas été raisonnable sur le sujet
dans le domaine des tos nous nous avons
diminué le nombre de postes dans les
collèges la région alors que le nombre
de lycéens diminuait à augmenter le
nombre de postes dans les collèges vous
préparez la ruine des finances de la
france vous préparez la désertification
de nos campagnes les communes
aujourd'hui nous demande de monter des
agences techniques pour les aider parce
qu'elles n'ont pas la possibilité je
m'arrête là et je reprendrai pour la
minute
la parole était monsieur andré vallini
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur d'abord j'ai la passion de mon
territoire de mon département j'y suis
né j'ai été maire de la petite ville
natale j'ai conseiller général du canton
de cette ville natale et je suis donc
depuis 22 ans conseiller général j'aime
beaucoup le département de l'isère je me
donne à fond dans les mandats locaux qui
m'ont été confiées par le suffrage
universel
pour autant je ne suis pas attaché à
l'institution conseil général
créée il ya
plus de 200 ans en 1790 devenu
collectivités locales en 1871 les choses
évoluent les choses bougent la société
évolue aussi donc on peut être attaché à
son territoire à son département à sont
canto et en même temps vouloir que les
institutions s'adapte à la société donc
je ne reviens pas sur ce que j'ai dit à
vos collègues il ya quelques instants au
fil des réponses que j'ai apporté des
intercommunalités plus grande plus
efficace pour la proximité
des régions plus grande plus efficace
pour la compétitivité quant à la gestion
des conseils généraux j'ai la fierté
avec mon équipe depuis 13 ans maintenant
de ne pas avoir augmenté les impôts du
département de l'isère depuis dix ans et
de d'avoir le département le moins
endetté de france en euros par habitant
est donc celui qui investit le plus en
euros par habitant parce que pas de
dette donc beaucoup d'investissement
donc en matière de gestion des
collectivités locales je je je peux je
peux en parler quand vous voulez
monsieur le sénateur mais les régions
pour demain être tout à fait capable
d'assumer les compétences que nous
allons leur transférer en déléguant
ensuite pour la proximité aux
intercommunalités le transport scolaire
voire même pourquoi pas l'entretien de
certaines routes ont fait des économies
d'échelle notamment sur les marchés
publics sur les services généraux sur la
paye la gestion des ressources humaines
mais ensuite pour la proximité on a les
rôles et des intercommunalités qui
seront là pour exercer au mieux au plus
près des habitants et de leurs besoins
les compétences donc ne vous inquiétez
pas monsieur le sénateur on va faire ça
ensemble en connaisseur de l'action
publique locale et je suis sûr qu'on
peut encore dépasser les clivages
partisans et faire une belle et grande
réforme territoriale suffit pas d'eau
oui monsieur le ministre je pense que
nous allons devoir faire quelque chose
s'est demandé à la cour des comptes de
chiffrer le coût de la réforme que vous
voulez mettre en place parce qu'il ya eu
énormément de mensonges d'énumérer et
moi je vous garantis que quand cette
analyse sera fait c'est une augmentation
de la dépense publique et pas pour
quelques années en permanence vous aurez
une augmentation de la dépense publique
tout ce qu'on a réussi à rationaliser
mais ça me fait sourire de penser que
vous allez donner demain les eaux les
enfants étrange les mineurs étrangers
isolés aux intercommunalités ils vont
être contents de s'occuper de ça et puis
vous qui voulez maintenant nationaliser
les pompiers vous allez être très
content de vous occuper d'augmenter la
dépense publique à chaque fois que vous
aurez besoin de traiter les problèmes
des pompiers vous nous avez demandé
aujourd'hui d'assumer à chaque fois
qu'il ya une augmentation
ce sont les départements qui s'en occupe
et vous voulez maintenant les re
nationaliser et ben je vous souhaite
bien du plaisir pour la dépense publique
je crois vraiment qu'il ya une urgence
et je pense que vous vous trompez
totalement sur la capacité des
intercommunalités elles n'ont même pas
fini de se regrouper ça doit se terminer
en 2017 elles n'ont pas encore décidé le
niveau de compétences qu'elles veulent
prendre et vous voulez déjà les remettre
sur l'ouvragé c'est de la folie pure ils
vont vous le dire au mois de septembre
aux prochaines élections sénatoriales
merci je vais suspendre de ses hanches
le chat collègues elle sera reprise à
16h pour la discussion de la question
orale avec débat numéro 9 de monsieur
jean daydé voilà vous avez donc pu
suivre en direct de l'hémicycle la
séance de questions cribles à des
questions cribles consacrée aujourd'hui
à la réforme territoriale tout de suite
la suite de nos programmes sur public
sénat